This is my morning commute.
I get up, get ready, get in a car, drive to the train station,
look for parking, get on a train for an hour and a half,
arrive at Penn Station, get another train,
walk five minutes, and start my work day.
Is this killing me?
Before you go and post that comment
telling me to move closer, you need to
see that I'm not the only person doing
this. This is the train station I commute
from. This place is huge and yet it's
full almost every single day. Just this
past fall they had to rip out an entire
section of trees to make more space for
parking and it's still not always enough.
According to US census data the average
American commute is nearly 30 minutes
one way, a number that's been on the rise
for the last few decades. In general,
people are choosing to commute further
and farther than ever before. And those
long grueling hours in cars, on trains,
or buses can take a toll on a person's
health. Especially when we all hate it so
very, very, much.
If you commute or you've been on the
internet at all, you've seen the articles
and maybe you've read the studies.
Commuting has been linked to higher
rates of obesity, stress, anxiety,
depression, higher blood pressure, higher
rates of divorce, neck and back problems,
shorter lifespans, and you get the point.
Commuting long distances just isn't good
for you. But a lot of it comes down to
how you do it. For example a Canadian
study of commuters in Montreal found
that people who walk, bike, or hop on a
train had a higher life satisfaction than
those with comparable commute times on
other types of transit. In another study,
British researchers found that people
who drive to work instead of using
public transportation are more likely to
be obese. Sitting in a car all day really
adds the negative effects of an inactive
lifestyle. You're sitting for hours on
end and when all is said and done it's
really hard to find the time or the
motivation to exercise. And that's not all.
Research has shown that driving alone in
particular can make you more miserable.
You're alone with your thoughts for
hours,
often in frustrating situations, so it's
not really surprising that this is the
disaster for both your mental and
physical health. Yet according to a 2010
report, this is exactly how 80% of
Americans commute to work every single day.
Now by comparison, those who take public
transportation are slightly healthier
and slightly more satisfied with life.
Yet we tend to be more negative about
our experience overall.
Public transit
commuters often resent the timetables. If
I don't leave work at 6 o'clock on the
dot, I won't catch the 6:21. if I don't catch
the 6:21 I have to get on the 6:53, and
that's the difference between me getting
home at 8:00 p.m. and me getting home at
8:45. Throw in things like transfers,
delays, cancellations, and you have a
really solid foundation for a very
stressful, very annoying commute.
Basically none of this is looking good
for my mortality.
Then why do so many of
us do it? Commuting has been viewed as a
source of stress, but in fact it gives
people a break. It's sometimes the only
hour of the day that individuals have
alone, to be by themselves to think, to
listen to music. Meaning my commute isn't
technically dead space in my day. I catch
up on reading, I listen to podcasts, I take
advantage of the alone time, but I can
also get work done when I need to. The
change in communications has made
commuting an extension of the workday or
an opportunity for the individual to do
things they couldn't otherwise do. It's
not just a way to go from point A to
point B. In other cases ,where people
live in the gig economy, having a
home that is accessible to
transportation is far more important
than having a home which is next to your
workplace. If you're not gonna have a
lifetime job let's have a lifetime home.
So is my commute actually killing me?
Well it's certainly not the best way to
spend so much of my time and it is
exhausting, but you can make the most of it.
And there's something to be said
about coming home at the end of it all